andrew yang has been a guest on this
program several times he is running for
president he is polling 3% in the most
recent Emerson National 2020 Democratic
primary poll getting more and more
attention last night he had a CNN Town
Hall really great stuff and it turns out
that the David Pakman show got a shout
out during the townhall now when I first
heard about this Pat texted me about it
and I thought Andrew yang himself gave
us a shout-out it turns out that the
shoutout was not from Andrew but it was
from a viewer of ours who got to ask a
question his name's Patrick lidtke check
this out from CNN last night Patrick
Luedtke is here he's originally from New
York he's now a student at the George
Washington University and is a member of
the College Democrats Patrick all right
so after your interview on David Pakman
show I decided to check out your policy
page and I noticed it doesn't make much
mention of unions what are your plans
for organized labor particularly in
light of the automation crisis yeah I'm
a huge Union fan and this freedom
dividend that I'm proposing was actually
championed initially by a guy named Andy
Stern who used to run the SEIU right so
that we'll get to the union stuff in a
second now the Power Move Pat would have
been for Andrew to say that's right
David Pakman did interview me I've been
going on his show for a year he's been
way ahead on universal basic income and
he's been covering my candidacy for a
long time which was not what he did but
it's still cool to get a mention yeah I
would have liked to have seen Andrew
yang just go on for two minutes about
the greatness of our show but
unfortunately he had to talk about
unions instead I think this could be a
good return on investment for us though
we'll just have to send Patrick the
check pretty soon yeah and putting it by
the way putting Andrew yang on Sunday
night not all of these panels have been
on Sunday evenings I think that there is
something interesting about that but
more importantly Andrew yang said a
bunch of stuff that I just don't agree
with during this Town Hall he's not for
unions great I would love to remove
unions from the middle of workers and
employers but as long as everything
stays the way it is right now in terms
of the power dynamics between non
contract employees and their employers
unions are a great tool anti-union
people will often say
all that money that the Union gets and
all that overhead and expense that the
Union represents that could all go to
the employees if the Union wasn't there
well sure it could but it wouldn't if
you simply remove the unions that's why
unions exist without unions those union
dues and the Union infrastructure costs
are kept by the employer the employer
doesn't say now that the unions gone
we'll give all the workers more money
that's just not how it works that's sort
of the whole point of unions to
negotiate better compensation for
employees also Andrew yang mentioned a
medicare-for-all buy-in during his Town
Hall which to me defeats the purpose if
you you're already sort of buying into
Medicare by paying taxes so there's
gonna be lots to discuss about Andrew
Yang's policy in the upcoming days that
definitely needs some exploration but
great great job here by a Patrick littky
mentioning the David Pakman show and I
said a while ago any any corporate media
mentions that people are able to get in
oh we will feature on the show and thank
people for doing whether their phone
calls into radio shows whether they are
if fox news happens to do one of these
person on the street interviews and you
get a mention of the david pakman show
in there that makes it onto fox news
whatever you will get significant praise
on the show Congrats to Patrick littky
popping up and in complete confident in
a totally confident and and strong
manner mentioning that he found out
about Andrew yang on the David Pakman
show a really nice job and appreciate
the exposure